on oublie que le protéger les femmes
c'est aussi protéger les enfants qui se
retrouvent souvent d'ailleurs ces
situations le gouvernement avait dit la
peur doit changer de côté moi je suis
désolé quand je vois ces mesures je ne
vois pas en quoi les agresseurs vont
avoir peur un bracelet électronique
pourquoi pas karim l'a dit il faut que
les messieurs quitte le domicile et qui
si jamais ils s'en approchent il aille
en prison et qu'on arrête de mettre les
vendeurs de shit en prison et qu'on
mette des hommes qui tapent leur femme
en prison
et pendant les chasses peur et que
derrière s'il le faut parce que parfois
dans une difficulté financière on
prélève leur salaire enfin la peur
change de côté là je trouve les mesures
un peu particulière on parle alors moi
je suis médecin je vous parlais de la
levée du secret médical suis très
partagé sur ce point là parce que si on
lève le secret médical peut-être que les
femmes vont se dire il demain si je veux
voir le médecin
il va peut-être en parler donc je n'irai
pas le voir et je pense qu'on va les
mettre en danger d'autant plus que quand
on lit ce qu'il propose ils nous disent
attention en cas de danger immédiat pour
la victime et de risque avéré de
renouvellement des violences
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un risque
immédiat pour la victime une claque ça
risque de danger immédiat est ce qu'on
va dire que trois points de suture
c'en est un dès le début il faut se
régaler liquide savoir un risque avéré
de récidive ou est-ce qu'on a placé le
curseur
maintenant il ya un an on peut pas dire
que le gouvernement est responsable des
hommes qui tapent leur femme c'est
évident mais ils sont responsables de la
sécurité des citoyens c'est à eux de
mettre les femmes en protégeant en de
les protéger et un volet qu'on oublie si
la prise en charge de l'alcool dans le
dans les trente mesures je les élus y en
a une qui nous dit prévenir et prendre
en charge les violences conjugales ni
aux addictions
je vous raconter ce qui s'est passé en
2018 sur les 121 film ici féminicide
dans 80% des cas l'alcool ou les drogues
est impliqué dans les meurtres
ce qui veut dire que les hommes sous
l'emprise de l'alcool deviennent plus
violents on le sait les études
internationales et scientifiques sont
claires l'alcool est un facteur majeur
dans les violences conjugales et ans
intéressés dans une étude prendre le
journal intime en 15 mois de femmes qui
ont subi des violences et on s'est rendu
compte que les jours où les hommes
consomment de l'alcool
le risque d'agression physique et x huit
on sait que les hommes passent à l'acte
dans 60% des cas dans les deux heures
qui suivent la consommation d'alcool et
derrière on a un gouvernement qui nous
dit le mois sans alcool en janvier c'est
pas possible je pense qu'il faut lutter
beaucoup plus fort il faut que la peur
change de côté faut mettre les moyens
on tombe souvent sur laquelle garrido
honduras et la démogagie les 3 milliards
mais la raison il ya de l'argent
pour les riches mais des femmes qui
meurent on ne trouve pas l'argent un
milliard on va pas se mentir c'est de
l'argent mais on peut faire cet effort
pour protéger des vies et madame merci
de votre témoignage
moi je suis papa aussi ça me glace le
sang d'entendre les sévices que les
enfants peut subir et j'espère qu'enfin
on les mettra en sécurité parce qu'on
met en femme
on met en sécurité les hommes les femmes
mais aussi les enfants